joining us now with more is the
president of Judicial Watch tom Fitton
and i can tell you as the former
chairman of the Oversight Committee
nobody did better work than Judicial
Watch in Tom Fit and Tom explained to us
what you've just uncovered in these new
emails that you've been able to see well
these are struck page emails emails that
we've been getting slowly from the FBI
and they show that the FBI
during the Clinton email investigation
the general counsel Baker was working
well basically eating out of the palm of
the hand of the lawyer for Cheryl Mills
and Heather Samuelson the two lawyers
for Hillary Clinton who helped her to
lead all those emails trying to figure
out ways to get them to testify in
places where there won't be media
stakeouts
the documents show they were giving them
heads up on press stories and even Peter
struck gets kind of fed up with the
gamesmanship he notes they get two
laptops where they've got the 60
thousand emails or what used to be the
60 thousand emails close half of them
were deleted and he says you know isn't
it interesting we're getting it now this
is this is kind of in-your-face
obstruction there at the same time you
have to remember while they're taking
care of Hillary Clinton they're working
with her campaign and bending over
backwards later in the year
you've got FBI lawyers it looks like
altering documents to target Trump whoa
what an outrage and you know what it's
one more piece of evidence that would
require in my view the Justice
Department to reopen the criminal
investigation into this whole issue yeah
and you look at part of these emails
were about a meeting with McCabe and
remember I believe it was McCabe's wife
who ultimately was running in a race and
the Clintons helping to do a fundraiser
where that money ultimately ends up in
his wife's pocket for our political
campaign how convenient but that's a
whole nother hour a segment tom Fitton
and judicial watching do amazing work
and thank you again for joining us
tonight on Hannity